[Música]
olá tudo bem sou gustavo e choupo
engenheiro eletrônico
passei os últimos 20 anos da minha vida
trabalhando como engenheiro em grandes
mineradoras em diversas funções
fifi falar pra vocês agora um pouco
sobre transformação pessoal
transformação profissional mas enfim nós
vamos falar de uma outra transformação
uma transformação maior nessa minha vida
de engenheiro e 2017 eu tive a
oportunidade de mudar e já estava
querendo empreender estava em uma
carreira bastante estressante muitas
responsabilidades
o equipe gigantesca é minha esposa me
falando olha você vai enfartar lá dentro
não tinha tempo pra minha família vivia
em viagens enfim 2017 eu resolvi fazer
uma grande transformação na minha vida
pessoal e profissional
saí de uma carreira executiva
consolidada com uma experiência uma
bagagem grande e resolvi transformar
empreender em algo completamente
diferente do que aquilo que estava
acostumado
me mudei para a china que era um dos das
minhas metas para esse empreendimento
com poucas certezas na minha bagagem eu
fui para lá dessa certeza que eu fui eu
fui pra estudar algum negócio a trazer o
brasil mas não sabia que seria tinha uma
idéia mas não fechei e uma ideia fixa
não tive minha mente aberta para trazer
o que realmente fosse o que me trouxesse
vamos dizer trazer empreender
estudei lá na minha primeira missão mais
de 26 negócios
hoje já são 50 negócios estudados na
china em 14 centros industriais
diferentes então assim viajei a china de
um lado ao outro para tentar realmente
trazer aquilo que me trouxesse que me
transformasse como profissional me
matriculei também uma universidade
chinesa porque fazer negócio com a china
é algo fácil é é algo bastante
complicado
a começar pela cultura a começar pela
barreira da distância que você tá
a língua é também um impeditivo então
assim foi uma decisão acertada me
matricular em uma universidade chinesa
para poder aprender realmente fazer
negócio com a china moderna
bom aí a pergunta primeira pergunta que
todos se fazem quando eu mudei para a
china mas como é que foi com relação à
comida você se acostumou
olha os primeiros 15 dias foram
complicados viu emagreci cinco quilos
aí a segunda pergunta você comeu
escorpião
pois é eu cheguei na china com essa
idéia fixa nem falei eu tenho que achar
um escorpião comer
se eu não sair daqui não tiver comido
escorpião chega no brasil que contará a
história de bom mas só que eu estava com
um ritmo muito grande de trabalho muito
focado não estava ali para fazer turismo
mas sobrou um tempinho lá quando eu tava
em ronco e aí sim eu gosto também de
cozinhar
falei já sei que eu vou fazer eu vou no
mercado municipal numa feira municipal e
lá eu vou achar o bendito escorpião eu
comer e aí fui gente foi uma experiência
fantástica conheci coisas e comidas que
assim nunca tinha visto na vida nem a
forma de alimentação do chinês é eu
aprendi a gostar e é igual ea gente tem
as comidas nossas em brasília há
desculpa a nordestina mineira a paulista
é mais ou menos assim eu me dei bem com
a comida camponesa que a comida que
parece mais com o com a mineira porque o
restante é às vezes é complicado você
comer algumas coisas por lá mas enfim
estava com o meu foco de achar um
escorpião rodei essa feira toda e nada
de achar um escorpião
aí parei numa barraquinha que tinha
algumas coisas meio exóticas e falei vou
perguntar aqui ele deve saber onde que
tem a barraca do escorpião que eu comer
rio chinês pegou pra minha cara rio
o lance não é coisa pra turista comer a
gente não come escorpião aqui não
e fui descobrir se a china não é gente
mas enfim lá tem escorpião para comer
mas em algumas regiões onde por exemplo
pequim em uma feira turística que vai só
turista e tem lá um espetinho escorpião
então quem quiser vai comer
lá eu não consegui como escorpião como
em outras coisas diferentes lá exóticas
é uma salada de insetos mas enfim é
experiências que vão deixar pra outra
outra história né
bom é o que eu vim falar aqui pra vocês
foi durante essa minha estada lá eu fui
aberto para estudar em negócios
o que me fascinou e o que eu quero
trazer de experiência realmente é a
transformação digital
a gente sempre escutou falar aqui a
china ela é moderna a china é o país do
futuro
gente eu não fiquei parado em 2017
esperando esse futuro é conhecida a
acontecer vir até mim eu fui até lá para
ver realmente essa transformação que
está acontecendo e se eu falo pra vocês
aliás se vocês querem ter uma
experiência de viagem ao futuro no
presente no momento presente se tiver
oportunidade vai para a china a vocês
vão ter essa sensação de está no futuro
bom vamos começar a imaginar um mundo
hoje
sem esses aplicativos aí o youtube
twitter e facebook instagram google maps
e sem o google
bom eu fiz essa brincadeira com a minha
filha isabella que tem oito anos ela
estava no banco de trás do carro a gente
gosta de brincar e perguntar coisas
aleatórias e a gente estava brincando
disso né
quando eu falei pra isabella sobre essa
essa suposição eu falei sobre o google
ela falou pai mas o google não como é
que nós vamos viver sem o google
isabella nasceu com o tablet na mão
então ela realmente não consegue viver
sem o google mas esse mundo eu vou falar
pra vocês esse mundo existe e ele é
muito melhor do que o nosso e muito mais
tecnológico esse mundo é a china
todos os nossos programas que a gente
usa aqui agora ea gente está acostumado
e apostar e tem muita gente já está
apostando no instagram a cantata quente
nada funciona lá é tudo bloqueado
todos os programas ocidentais nossos lá
são bloqueados bom e aí antes de eu ir
para a china estava estudando junto com
a minha esposa
como é que seria a vida na china e me
deparei nem gente como é que vai ser
os nossos programas são bloqueados lá
como é que é
me comunicar com o brasil aí comecei a
amib a procurar o que realmente eu iria
utilizá la como eu disse esse mundo
existe e ele é melhor do que o nosso só
que com um grande diferencial
estamos acostumados hoje com a internet
é uma terra de ninguém todo mundo possa
o que quer fala o que quer
na china não é assim você pode até
gostar mas o governo chinês
ele pode te procurar depois então na
verdade lá não é uma internet é uma
grande e internet com grande firewall e
que está sendo todo momento ali moniz
sendo monitorado pelo governo chinês
bom mas e sobre os programas chineses
lá tem os paralelos então por exemplo no
twitter tenho o e bo ou em mandarim em
embu
o google nós temos o pai do o pai do
youtube o yuko
vou parar por aí né e sinal mandarino é
tão bom assim e aí eu tô começando a
falar besteira né
agora imagine o seguinte imagina você
pegar e várias mídias sociais como
facebook instagram o whatsapp e ainda
jogar lá dentro um banco 24 horas e
dentro disso e como esse gigantesco e
mais tudo isso funcionando ele de uma
forma muito precisa e gerando uma big
data imaginar isso daí
isso existe é esse aplicativo aqui o tal
do micheletti e chefe eu baixei para
conversar com a minha esposa e que
achava que era só um programa de chat
normal igual a ti zap mandar a foto
digital e voz gente esse negócio
fantástico está revolucionando o
comércio digital na china aliás está
revolucionando toda a china
só para vocês terem uma ideia é no chat
juntando e chatila ipi passaram nesses
programas é um pouco um aplicativo mais
de 3 trilhões de dólares 3 5 trilhões de
dólares americanos só pra gente fazer
uma comparação só quando que o pib
brasileiro é 1.7 bilhão de dólares
dentro de dois aplicativos passaram
quase que duas vezes o pib brasileiro e
se pra comparar com os estados unidos
que todo mundo acha que é a a potência
mais consumista tá enganado é porque não
conhece a china olha os números aí que
estão explicando 112 bilhões passaram em
aplicativos tipo amazon nos estados
unidos enquanto 3 trilhões de dólares
passaram na china então veja como que
está acontecendo essa transformação
digital lá
bom vou dar um exemplo aqui para ficar
claro de como isto funciona tá então
pegar um exemplo de um pet é um pet ele
tem as necessidades ele precisa de banho
ele precisa de tosa né
aí de repente você está navegando e chat
e você vê que um amigo seu amiga sua cor
postou que tem um pet shop prestando o
serviço lá dentro do seu apartamento
fazendo um serviço de tosa e banho você
foi lá e curtiu achou legal aquilo ali
né
de repente o que acontece já passa já
chega ali pra você informação daquele
prestador de serviço isso tudo dentro do
mesmo aplicativo no site do aplicativo e
aí de repente você já vê lá a tabela com
os horários disponíveis você olha opa
ele tem um horário aqui para a próxima
hora vou agendar e já agenda agenda ele
então saiu da casa do seu amigo você
acompanha pelo mapa ele já vai para sua
casa para prestar o serviço
só que nessa suposição vamos dizer que
essa pessoa que está agendando serviço
ela está trabalhando e não tem ninguém
na casa dela poxa como é que eu vou
mandar um prestador de serviço não tem
ninguém em casa quem vai abrir a porta e
como é que você vai deixar alguém atrás
sim gente na china tudo funciona a
internet das coisas
as casas são inteligentes então por
exemplo tem dispositivos campanhas
inteligentes que antes da pessoa tocar a
campainha
você vai estar bem já que o prestador de
serviço está lá na sua porta vai tirar
uma foto e vai te mostrar olha tem
alguém lá aí você a pessoa aperta a
campanha você faz uma vídeo chamada em
tempo real e conversa com o prestador de
serviço
assim eu já combinou e aí o cara não tem
a chave da sua porta
não precisa gente internet das coisas
pega o celular mano no comando ele com a
sua senha a fechadura abre o cara entra
e aí vem a preocupação de brasileiros
mas desse roubar o cara vai lá vai
roubar primeiro que na china a gente é
complicado questão de roubo
não vou entrar nos detalhes não mas eles
não rouba são bastante honestos né
aliás não posso afirmar com 100% de
certeza mas na maioria são mais do nosso
povo em todos os dispositivos ali no
momento que estão monitorando aquele
serviço que estão acontecendo então por
exemplo câmeras que não são simples
câmeras são câmeras inteligentes que
estão demandando as informações do que
está ocorrendo ali e você está
acompanhando tudo em tempo real
beleza a estão dispositivos então você
vai ligar por exemplo a iluminação da
sua casa para receber o prestador de
serviço você vai abrir a cortina as
luzes vão se entender você liga
dispositivos estudo pelo aplicativo ou
você deixa que a casa tome decisão por
você e faça sozinha em tempo real
e daí como é que eu vou pagar o cara
estou trabalhando o cara tá lá aí de
novo né gente chat em dois cliques você
mandou dinheiro para a conta do cara
pronto tá pago ele já se você já confere
lá que ele recebeu
ele diz pede pra você através da sua
câmera inteligente vai embora próximo
serviço e você vai acessar por exemplo
um alimentador inteligente que tem
câmera que tem com os sistemas de
comunicação e seu cãozinho acabou de
sair de uma a de um stress ali que teve
uma tosa teve um banho você vai
conversar com ele chama ele pra comer
tudo automaticamente pelo seu smartphone
bom ea big data como é que funciona
nessa relação porque tudo está gerando
informações é todo esse consumo toda
essa movimentação isso funciona de uma
forma muito legal gente de cima para
baixo de baixo pra cima então assim é
tanto trazendo benefício para as grandes
empresas trazendo benefícios dos médios
empreendedores para as pessoas e para os
consumidores
todas essas informações trazendo
benefício vamos dar um exemplo o leite o
leite é uma coisa complicada na china a
china ela teve problemas sérios de
contaminação de leite leite com é baixo
nível
enfim não vou falar dos detalhes aqui
mas lá ele só compra o leite de marcas
que realmente eles conhecem ou
informações de boca a boca é fulano que
comprou que fez com o filho dele que o
leite é bom que não sei que é e passa
informação pegando essa big data e essa
informação do leite tem todo o perfil de
consumo de quem são as famílias eu tenho
dois filhos por exemplo eu sabia
exatamente quando meu filho é tinha ali
a idade que ele estava tomando leite né
quanto custava uma lata de leite quanto
estava o litro de leite a caixa de leite
então assim pra quem tem aquele consumo
aquele hábito diário sabe que por
exemplo se jogar o litro do leite a uns
50 você vai comprar três caixas porque
ele custa r$3 as empresas têm essa
informação e elas jogam de forma de
maneira precisa mas não direto do
consumidor
ela joga nas pessoas que estão naquela
cadeia lhe dê de distribuição de
informação então aquelas pessoas que
estão na cadeia de de informação joga
para baixo e todo mundo ganha a empresa
ganha a pessoa que está no meio ganho
percentual e o consumidor ganha ganha
porque comprou um produto com desconto e
logística de exportação a custar povo
comprar leite pelo aplicativo pois é
complicado vai demorar uma semana para
entregar gente na china as coisas
funcionam e logística é extremamente
rápida funciona que é uma maravilha o
leite por exemplo eu comprei ele deitado
a dez horas da noite na minha cama 6
horas da manhã e está entregue de novo a
candidata ela tem informação ali
daqueles perfis de consumidores já sabe
os cds onde estão leite tem toda a
informação pra os distribuidores e assim
eles distribuem de uma forma muito
rápida de motocicletas elétricas carros
elétricos é tudo pequenininho assim é
muita gente para trabalhar tem que
entregar todo mundo então gente a
bicicleta toda hora e entrega toda hora
e sim então no caso do leite em seis
horas 8 horas está lá na sua casa e
outro problema
esse é um problema que está acontecendo
no papel-moeda ele está assumindo na
china
quando eu fui pra lá eu tive problema
porque eu levei cartão de crédito
é treva o cheque e tem repente eu
comecei a passar o cartão não funcionava
só funciona o tal do chat
eu não tinha uma conta chinesa para usar
o cheque o dinheiro sumiu de circulação
onde estão as oportunidades e olha que
número lindo esse até o ano que vem
mais de 4 trilhões de dólares vão gerar
de oportunidades e internet das coisas
isso daqui é do fórum que eu fui são
paulo que eu que inventei número lindo
esse daí onde estão as oportunidades
internet das coisas dispositivos
internet de conectados o tempo todo
smartwatt medidores de pressão que manda
a lei a pressão pros filhos para tomar
conta por exemplo dos pais manda direto
pro médico e se tem alguma variação você
já recebe na hora
a cidade inteligente nós estamos sendo
pioneiros aí fazendo o teste parcerias
com universidades para testar cidades
inteligentes com a rede lora de longo
alcance uma rede que é você trafega
dados tanto pra você ligar a iluminação
pública sinaleiros é trafegar imagens
enfim uma rede fantástica e que vem para
revolucionar e trazer as cidades
inteligentes casas inteligentes acabei
de dar um exemplo pra você dispositivos
como campanhas sistema de fechaduras
iluminação tudo funcionando e conectando
trazendo informação em tempo real
a gente sai do sistema passivo e passa
com o sistema ativo de segurança onde
vigilância ou de conforto a indústria
4.0 que tá vendo aí é a quarta revolução
industrial para revolucionar então
sensores dispositivos conectados aos
motores que estão a todo momento
mandando diagnósticos está em falha no
utah e aí você faz uma manutenção
planejada e programada pra fazer aquela
manutenção e aquela substituição a
planta não pára porque quebra a
construção 4.0 impressoras imprimindo
casas populares em em menos de um dia né
e com 23 dias
bom e aí a pergunta pra você eu faço pra
vocês e vocês onde vocês vão começar a
transformação digital usando o exemplo
da borboleta a última fase dela
aqui é a transformação digital meu muito
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]